When thinking about taxes you might
think of country music Westons George
Bush and a certain ranger will be
aimless.
However Texas is far more than these
overused cliches.
Frank.
In the last few years Texas has become
one of the most important drivers of
higher U.S.
economy.
And Texas is what we're going to be
telling you about in this video.
With over 270000 square miles.
Texas is 3 times the size of the entire
United Kingdom.
In addition to that Texas is one of the
largest states in the U.S.
In fact it is the second largest behind
only Alaska.
Texas is located in the southern region
of the United States known as the Sun
Belt.
It has a coastline along the Gulf of
Mexico and also borders Mexico itself.
This border with Mexico stretches for
over 1200 and 50 miles.
The Lone Star State may strike some as a
hostile wasteland but there is far more
to it than that there are in fact four
seasons.
The drought the flood the blizzard and
the tornado season this harsh climate
has not prevented Texas from becoming
the 12th largest economy in the entire
world.
It is also the fastest growing state in
the United States by population numbers.
It creates the most jobs in the United
States and is responsible for the most
exports.
Since 2000 the population of Texas has
increased by six million people which is
more than any other states.
An additional one point five million
Americans have moved to Texas in search
of a better future for many.
Texas has become a place where you go
when you're looking for a fresh start.
It's a popular place for people to go if
they've lost their job in their states.
According to data published by the U.S.
Census five out of eight of the cities
that grew the most in the United States
in 2015 were in Texas.
Additionally 40 percent of the 27
million people who live in Texas are of
Latino heritage.
Furthermore it is estimated that by 2020
Hispanics will be the majority in the
state.
This will make Texas the world's second
largest economic Hispanic power.
This is only behind California which
already has a majority Hispanic
population.
Also the Republican candidate for
governor Greg Abbott has released his
first television ad and it's in Spanish
and the 21st century.
Texas has led job creation in the United
States in the last 16 years employment
in Texas has tripled the national
average in the same period.
Texas has created a million more jobs
than California a state which has 12
million more people.
Since the beginning of the financial
crisis in December 2007 Texas which
represents about 8 percent of the U.S.
population has been responsible for one
out of every four jobs created in the
country.
So it's no surprise that unemployment is
lower than the U.S.
average and has been that way for the
last ten years.
Also in the same period Texas's GDP has
enjoyed a 60 percent growth while the
rest of the country has had to settle
for 35 percent.
Also as I was saying earlier it is the
states that exports the most and 52 of
the Fortune 500 largest companies are
based in Texas.
Having said all of this is no surprise
that people consider Texas to be the
true economic driver of the U.S..
Now it is true that Texas has suffered
because of the fall in oil prices but
many people believe that due to its
increasingly diversified economy it will
still lead the way in the United States.
So you might be asking now what exactly
is so special about Texas.
Town planning regulations.
For middle and low income workers the
best part of Texas is the price of
housing.
These workers have access to big and
affordable homes.
This happens because regulation in the
state is very flexible and it means that
homes can be built but not much more
than the cost of the labor and net
component parts.
Between 2001 and 2008 Harris County
which includes Houston authorized the
building of 200000 homes.
This is compared to just 16000 in Santa
Clarita in California which by the way
includes Silicon Valley.
A new houses being built every five
acres in Texas.
This is compared to one being build
every 50 in California.
This means that even if you make less
money in Texas you'll probably be able
to afford a better home.
If you live in that state.
University.
Texas has been able to develop one of
the best university systems in the world
even though it only has a population of
27 million people four of the world's
top 100 universities all located in the
state.
For some perspective on Nasik country
like Spain which has a far larger
population it has no universities in the
top 100.
The education system in Texas not only
creates high quality professionals but
also attracts investments from a lot of
companies.
Texas.
Regulations.
On them all leaving.
Texas is a state where salaries provide
generally high in value because the cost
of many things in Texas is lower than in
other states.
People also have more money in their
parties because of the lower housing
prices and the lower taxes in the state.
The taxes are lower because Texas is one
of only seven states that have new state
level income tax as a reference point.
The average family living in Texas
compared to New York will save three
thousand five hundred dollars per year
in taxes.
All Things Considered Texas is the fifth
best state for getting the most from
your salary.
Besides this Texas is considered one of
the states with the most freedom.
It is ranked sic recording to the Fraser
Institute.
This means that it is significantly
easier to do business in Texas than
compared to some other states.
Further there are fewer regulations
around jobs for example in Nevada
Louisiana or Florida.
The requirement to qualify as an
interior designer is 2190 hours of work
and you also have to take a course in
taxes.
There is no such requirement and anyone
can go out and become an interior
designer.
As a result of this many millennials
have been choosing Houston as a place to
set up a business rather than more
traditional choices like New York City
or Boston.
Many Americans are starting to think
that other states could start to emulate
Texas in some ways.
Not only are there the tangible benefits
of running a state in the way Texas does
but there are also several cultural
benefits.
Texas's economic boom has attracted a
great deal of cultural and ethnic
diversity contributing to cities like
Austin becoming a great place for
musicians and other types of artist.
Texas can teach us that it is possible
to fight the negative effects of
globalization as well as the automation
of jobs by machines and they haven't
done this by protecting their companies
from foreign competition.
They've done it by reducing the
obstacles that companies and individuals
face in the state.
Every week businesses lead Californians
to escape high taxes and strangling
regulations.
They come to Texas because we keep taxes
low.
So this is just our opinion on taxes
here a visual politic and we would love
to know what you think.
Do you use the comments below to let us
know your opinion.
Do you think that more states will stop
following the example of Texas and what
do you think do you think the Trump
presidency could turn this historically
Republican state into a democratic one
by 2020.
Do you think Texas is ever a place you
could see yourself living as I say.
Let us know in the comments.
Do you subscribe we put our Brenly
videos just like this every Monday every
Thursday also if you enjoy this video
hit that thumbs up button.
Bolo me now and I'll see you next time.